[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight for generations the SAT measured
how much she knew about academic
subjects English and math the new woke
version judges students on their
privilege want to get your kids into
Harvard will get divorced and moved to a
bad neighborhood more on that story in
just a minute
but first tonight if a man runs for
president but nobody supports him is it
really a presidential campaign that's a
philosophical question obviously but
it's also suddenly a very practical
concern for Bill DeBlasio the mayor of
New York
de Blasio announced today that after
years of destroying the nation's largest
city he'd very much like to do the same
thing to America watch there's plenty of
money in this world there's plenty of
money in this country it's just in the
wrong hands I'm a New Yorker I've known
Trump's a bully for a long time
this is not news to me or anyone else
here and I know how to take them on
Donald Trump must be stopped
I've beaten him before and I will do it
again I'm bill de blasio and I'm running
for president because it's time we put
working people first well spoiler alert
bill de blasio is never going to be the
President of the United States he's dumb
he's unpopular he's almost comically
incompetent he's exactly the kind of
person who should not be smoking a lot
of marijuana but apparently is anyway
that's bill de blasio the good news is
he's also kind of entertaining if you
don't have to live in his city so while
we still can sit back and enjoy the
buffoonery there's a lot of it it began
today with his announcement video in
which de Blasio pledged to fight for
working people while being driven by a
chauffeur around the streets of New York
even CNN which has been happy to promote
transparent phonies like Kirsten
Gillibrand and Peabody Judge was not
impressed and there's a palpable lack of
excitement in the streets of New York
three-quarters of New Yorkers don't want
him to run one of the big problems that
bill de blasio is he is not showing up
to work he comes in late he doesn't come
in at all
he seems utterly disinterested in the
job of running America's largest big
city and again this is somebody who has
been under
water often in the polls in a city
that's six to one Democrat I don't have
any friends who are excited about Bill
de Blasio for president so if you're
Bill de Blasio this has got to hurt it
stings CNN was supposed to be a critical
ally in this race
unfortunately CNN is based in New York
City and that means its employees know
exactly how incompetent their mayor is
they have to wade through piles of
garbage to get to work every morning
MSNBC is headquartered in New York City
too and you can tell from the way they
covered de Blasio's announcement watch
he's not what anyone would call popular
back home in New York last month in a
Quinnipiac poll 76% of New Yorkers said
that they do not think he should run for
president what do you think about mayor
de Blasio announcing he's running for
president I don't know I fear he has a
lot of stuff to do in New York City
first I'm not encouraged by his policies
in the city it's about a woman runs this
country I think you should announce on
the 1st of April and why that because it
would have been a good April Fool's Day
joke
ouch at this point if you personally are
excited for Bill de Blasio presidency
please let his campaign know you're
likely qualified for a paid staff
position the whole effort is so
obviously doomed everyone knows it
including you think mrs. de Blasio so
why is the bias t of running for
president well the same reason he ran
for mayor of New York narcissism bill de
blasio represents the worst strain of
American liberalism smug arrogant
utterly hypocritical and lacking in
self-awareness this is the man who
announced his own Green Deal but then
took a helicopter to the gym this is a
guy who sends cops into the subway to
shoo homeless people out of the way
before he rides it but then lets the
city drown in trash he demands you stop
eating hot dogs because they're bad but
then promotes smoking weed Bill de
Blasio is the only person in New York
who has no idea what an idiot Bill de
Blasio is he's totally mediocre but
completely self-confident
it's an amazing combination less weird
than you'd think unfortunately bill de
blasio is not going to be President but
he will be on television for a while our
advice try to stay amused